we're taking another trip back on memory
lane Ione does that ring a bell if I say
that I would meet me
those were the temps those were the
terms man back in November 2011 I play
this game it's one of my first let's
place wow that looks really good that
webcam well I can totally I can totally
see everything I wanted to replay this
game cuz it's not that long if I
remember correctly somehow I managed to
get this to nine parts like in favorite
for moiré it's one of the classics okay
so I thought we'd check it out
there we go this one just starts it as
an ask for your name apparently in the
outskirts of the city there's an
uninhabited mansion rumor has it that
the place is haunted
good good story I don't remember tecora
whatsoever
the interior is cleaner than I thought
Takashi what are these these images are
totally different Takeshi hey that's
enough let's go home
what's your a deck a sheet that I would
give this stupid voice I remember it oh
man what's round occasion you scared
wait Orochi okay so you the main
character his Roshi
this is an RPG maker horror game there
was I think three of them Abe Ione and
the witch house those three are like
legendary there's also a couple extra
ones they're really good as well but I
remember those were the first ones I
played and I'll never forget them
because you know the game looks kind of
dumb not gonna lie the game looks dumb
but is extremely efficient and story to
end in mixing storytelling and or a
broken plane shard obtained okay so we
got a shard
because what a lot of people forget is
that horror is about the simplicity it's
not a that's why all these like okay
Georgian line could I use the chard
perhaps I just don't know the control
doesn't work okay that's why a lot of
hard horror movies work really well
because they're even though they're
really cheap because it's about the
simplicity people forget it
bigger is not better let's take all this
Silent Hill games let's go back oh my
god they're gone I don't know why they
teach two pictures why would they change
the pictures where is everybody oh my
god there's two ow
Unni is this for oh the door won't open
okay I got it the first time thank you
all right none of these doors will open
where should we go then perhaps upstairs
it is so fun to revisit I hope it
doesn't seem like I'm just trying to
milk these games twice it's legit like
I'll own it's a great game I don't
remember much of it it's nostalgic as
[ __ ] boy none of these doors will open I
think this one none of the [ __ ] doors
will open and I still don't seem to it's
really strange controls in this version
oh okay we can go in here excellent oh
my god how long it's it's Takeshi my man
teeth all right he's super spook dad I
remember you can move that yeah all
right we got the library key
don't worry Takeshi I got you fam I'm
gonna come back and save you dog I have
no idea where the library is but I'm
sure I can find it I just got a check
every single God actually I think the
library is on top for some stupid reason
see if I remember nope
oh my god what was that where did he go
I think I only means blue troll how is
blue actually know that and only must
patrol then there we go bedroom key
obtained [ __ ] alright forgot he keeps
going he keeps going oh my god that is
actually freaky let me load [ __ ] I let
him god damn are you kidding me what a
fail what a flip and fail me
[Music]
okay we're gonna go to where Takeshi was
as scary as this is we have to use oh my
it is freaky I'm not gonna lie man it's
freaky man
Takeshi my main no so bad oh I guess we
goose but I don't like me I just ended
the episode there are great Felix I like
how the main character has my hair as
well here we are back get in the game
oh my god he follows you anywhere oh
this store is oh my god you can't go
anywhere six years of gaming and I still
haven't learned [ __ ] this is so pole
[ __ ]
oh my god what do I have come on come on
I've never taken a crappy man biggest
fine I don't know what to do why am I
playing this conversion man all the way
around
come on fam ain't scared of you
oh okay so you just got to dodge him for
a while that was that was different than
my version but fine okay we have a lot
of places we can go now this room was
open for example I don't know that
that's a cute bathroom or not oh look we
find something a key to the Attic now
I'll just check that [ __ ] out my gosh
stupid game stupid game I don't remember
how to play you so you make me angry
game all right now we can go here hello
red chair another door oh wow that is
just fantastic were we supposed to know
okay we have a place we can hide now at
least great there's nothing stuck Hesh
is still here yo Takeshi hankerchief
obtained oh yeah we got we got his
hankerchief for a little takeshi's
hankerchief alright we got the bedroom
key this is the bedroom
um this is great no I'm glad I'm glad I
discovered the bedroom cuz this is just
fabulous I'm sort of glad I'm playing it
wait
floor does look different here maybe
that's a shadow or something I'm glad
I'm playing action at different rush
because it makes it a little trickier
cuz I don't remember everything
obviously all right this is Renu gotta
inspect everything in these games oh
look who it is
my man Tucker oh he was she all right
yeah same hey you know she I have you
seen me the tool there monster yes but
it's still hard to believe that such a
creature could exist I remember that
line on top of that all the all the
exits are sealed
we got himself trapped man it seems to
be here let's split up and search for
some more I'll look around the first
floor good leg let's split up
first rule of horror there's something
written beneath the picture stretched
them side by side which one is longest
which one small then line them all up
all right small at the bottom on top the
tall stretch them wish as long as which
is small then line them up small at the
bottom top but oh this is a puzzle what
I do not remember this one stretch defin
v okay
is it alphabetic perhaps
now
first I thought it was the periodic
system
stretched them out
stretch them
these are all similar this one is
different I do remember this game had a
bunch of like impossible puzzles in it
remember the piano puzzle or something
like that I'm sure there's a clue I need
to find somewhere before I solve this
let's keep checking all the bedrooms
okay let's just do that how about a what
is this is that the floor layout oh did
I take it so we got a mat now I don't
know why that would help us but okay I'm
great thank you thank you very much game
okay that door won't open
fine geez
okay there's something there I see it on
top of the bookshelf there we go just
push mr. chair oil oil in and
hankerchief we can make a Molotov and
killed that [ __ ] incredible
is there a combined thing you can do no
maybe it gets dark later Oh No
what yeah out of here man Oh No
all right we just got to let him I
haven't saved so it would be great if
you didn't kill me that would just be
super okay all right
he's not that hard to deal with if you
just get to that quick let's tear save
there whoa where was I
this looks new this looks different oh
god damn it are you kidding me it's K
man how did I get 10 9 parts out of this
of 13 parts okay Brooke Taney no there's
also a weird South Park mod tune to this
game all right let's trigger it
let's get over here good thing I stayed
our God he's got the shortcut on me he's
got the shortcut on me you are slightly
faster than him this table is the best
man what you gonna do huh what you gon
do all right I think that should be okay
another save another say Pat silver
Blair thank you I like how the game
counts how many steps I've taken cuz
that's important
all right so now we can go in here
properly now okay was just it was just
chilling in there excellent Oh something
here lighter
okay so we have lighter oil and
hankerchief yeah can I hide in these
what's the point huh
why do people like this game again out
of Adam so now we can use the lighter
when it gets dark
was there a place that was dark in the
game detergent
what soak the hankerchief sure why not
and then Lionel it it now okay I don't
know what I'm doing okay I'm just trying
out different things me clearly I'm not
playing the right game here okay we've
got to check these rooms out again we
still have a plate shard for some
goddamn reason I would love to make a
game like this I love this game they
have so much charm I don't know what it
is the simplicity just works I think
there was like a hidden room in one of
these I think we might have to just
solve one of the puzzles a memo obtained
whoa okay I did I did say I saw
something gonna read this
now that's some sexy [ __ ] ow this is say
I remember this stupid puzzle some of
the keys we use the memo here right
because those are piano notes right
they are [ __ ] I don't know me then I
don't know hey look at that it's it
we need a pin okay that's the door is
unlocked
okay so we can go here now let's do it
safe okay so we use the handkerchief to
wash it off 2:39 oh my god what the haha
this guy this guy keeps popping up and
the worst possible times man okay 2 3 2
3 9 oh okay all right
we're fine we're fine a lady by the bed
being what are you gonna do out you name
you never gonna get a girlfriend like me
you're never gonna get a girl with the
pants like me oh yeah two three nine is
that the password to dis safe perhaps
could be two three nine let's try it
probably nine it worked
used a lighter to heat the memo yes of
course why would an eye not think of
that what does that say six nine and one
nine
hey look at that
we got the nursery room Queen stupid
piano puzzle I remember you
you don't make any goddamn sense Fu main
we get the nursery key I don't even know
where that goes what is that take me to
the nursery I remember it's one of the
weirdest puzzles I've ever seen in a
game the goddamn piano puzzle thank you
hey look who it is
my man look how sexy she looks so you're
safe
look he really cares a lot doesn't he
what about the others well we got
separated so I see follow me
are you kidding like I run around the
house or the monster in it I see
Sokka so Disney oh my oh let's do a save
on this [ __ ] oh what's the point then
huh go away there's a bulge maybe we can
use the shard
wow so smart we got a screwdriver now
I'm a screwdriver you am i right
you like this no [ __ ] you
I remember now guys don't worry okay I'm
professional you use the screwdriver
right on the doorknob if only I learned
the goddamn controlled or so on
intuitive
I got a doorknob everyone okay what do I
do with the [ __ ] Norden what I gotta
do now the goddamn doorknob huh it's the
goal just to spell out milf or what's
the point of this puzzle can someone
please explain to me what the hell the
point oh look at that Wow we got another
no no leave me alone
just see me I know all your tricks Pam I
know all your tricks what are you gonna
do what's what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do huh what are you gonna do
look he's crying look at him so sad I
just wanna hug man I don't know what I
did
oh my god I need him to actually come
here thank you bye-bye a batch thank you
for the save
okay now we're gonna go down cuz I
remember this 100% gonna have bad the
thing here I wonder what these lines
represent the meaningless of life and
how we're all going to die one day okay
what is this path though those one gets
a pass huh
the poses are way too hard man I am
playing an impossible game this game is
impossible how did I beat this easy okay
this is actually kind of creepy I'm
gonna say there of course oh my god are
you kidding me
so if you don't enter the past where you
just died Skippy's ridiculous
the thing is saved okay so need the
password what was a stupid cipher yeah
it's xxxx extent the film gonna come in
here do a stupid [ __ ]
[Music]
wait so you're telling me if it touches
the line it's a five and then you add
the other ones touching so this is a one
then that's six and that's four that
doesn't make any sense why is it a five
just because it's touches okay so that's
5 plus 2 7 3 1 no five seven three five
one right seven three five one okay
according to this seven three five one
seven three five one easy
shut up shut the [ __ ] up if I get it
wrong now I'm gonna die wish I'm a genie
away you come
by punch saved mother flipping saved son
oh god it flickered my god as a bookie
I can't touch maybe that's a chair oh I
remember this this is when the game gets
weird man
the game just weird from here on oh look
at that oh wow it's flickering like
crazy
I remember you have to do something with
the chair right oh look who's back again
shut up okay you let you love me don't
you
maybe a little bit of spaghetti suckers
what is the point do i neva do it it's
not gonna be her anymore is it okay
you're still there that's cute I waited
for you points I love you cuz I am a
chair' look at that boy look at that how
long do I add 2 to 6 stupid [ __ ] man
gotta get that oak please thank you
we got a diary everyone it's just what I
wanted
X X x equals 9 0 9 1 ok that puzzle was
a bit more straightforward and what are
we
the puzzles in this game man just stop I
think is that what this is the puzzle
that you can do upside down right 8 1 5
1 equals 5 9 8 2 2 1 6 9
yeah there's an upside down er I just
realized we have to push this goddamn
chair all the way back are you kidding
me
how did I play this game it's so hard
seriously this most difficult game I
have ever played but you love me [ __ ]
forgot about this metal rod up here look
at that
metal rod obtained if only I could do
that in real life
am i right cuz that's how hard I wanna
be okay a rat the doors locked but we
have the metal that seems to be slotted
attachment but the screw dress what does
that mean maybe the circuit board or
something there was a circuit board down
here maybe that's it god damn putts in
the game had never ends
it never ends goddammit I came for the
nostalgia all I got is Parcells
okay so apparently what you have to do
is you gotta you gotta go here and click
here and there's a torn page of course
of course why would I not check there
why would I not check there you know
you're right now we have a torn page for
some goddamn reason
oh my god Hey look at that it's a secret
room of course you would check twice of
course good thing I have my lighter okay
all right we have it we have this
screwdriver thing it's okay
shape screwdriver wow they all came off
at the same damn mag god the way what
the cop shut up the power appears to be
cut up so we can't do anything that's
fine listen me just orient between this
goddamn mace oh he's here oh great a
good thing I saved there oh my god this
is fantastic
Oh Mike are you kidding me you have to
be kidding me I don't know where the
doors are I can't see the doors
Oh oh my god let's hope No
leave me the hell alone
how is it still chasing me man how Oni
more like gaoli go away this is
ridiculous I'm going I'm going and you
better not chase me from here oh my god
this game is insane this game is insane
how did I play this
I would came in like oh it's gonna be so
strong it's gonna be some fun to play
this game again oh okay hang on I just
need to solve this stupid puzzle with a
math thing that is upside down [ __ ]
where was it was here right oh but then
the answer is upside down as well isn't
it
so it's five to eight nine no well [ __ ]
you too then yes ah annex key give me a
save before the stupid blue son of [ __ ]
oh wow
the puzzles are really hard they're
really tricky look we are here now
what do we got we got oh I remember this
thing what the flipper e they're a
little different nothing oh oh oh oh
so take a look at me now oh my god stop
just stop just stop
just stop just stop stop stop stop oh my
god
leave me alone this no is right up my
alley
okay surely now he's gonna stop thank
you thank you thank you thank you babe
domo arigato
my name is heroic she I am a hero going
from the top to the bottom like a sail
bro I will clear yo Fiero with my Talib
boom badda Bing badda Bing badda boom Oh
Oh what you gonna do I push you down the
shoe hey help
toodaloo buh-bye Luke better but don't
put your boots where the hell did he go
then
what I push it down here Fame that crazy
hey we have a box everybody know about
bang look at that push more [ __ ]
holes we got oil son we got oil and a
paper oh my god okay so now we can go in
the rain maybe maybe I don't know I
don't remember any of this doesn't work
anymore yes
hey look at that I can I can see will
get a blue jewel
what is this Sonic huh oh because we
pushed down the thing of course Oh what
do you say purple a puppet okay so we
got a jewel and a puppet we've got a
jewel and a puppet butter now I know
it's luck just be quiet please
what would those goddamn dolls huh where
were they bottom floor I think bottom
ploy they were over here no okay
there were over here yes okay yeah okay
so this one oh no no Wall Street Journal
stop it and then this this one okay so
this one has two eyes right and this one
has no eyes okay
and we got to make the match we got to
make the match I remember this a member
but why do we have one extra them
one of the puppies eyes is red but I
can't be good
hey we made a nice little fire I just
burn my puppet oh okay great so now we
can [ __ ] with the puppets right
they all need eyes is that what is it
okay so this one clearly wants am i
right
okay and then you want another one I got
you fam you look hella free oh that's
not creepy at all
not creepy at all we got the puppets
head ah good luck on your journey /
thank you
okay what are we gonna do with puppet
head there was a puzzle
there was a puzzle right over here no it
was in one of the rooms
hey let's say let's add an impossible
puzzle in there that'll that'll get him
look at that boy look at that boy key to
the third floor oh yeah oh yeah man look
at that [ __ ] third floor huh look at
that [ __ ] BAM oh he's creeping mr.
ionely is creeping peeping okay got him
another hustle up just ran just great
just quit
[ __ ] sincerely
whose Oh God just leave me the hell
alone
oh that was easy like spaghetti sauce
huh just falls into place I hate him I
genuinely hate him I want him to die now
before I thought it was cute there's a
plank named to the window good thing we
have a shape screwdriver
we got a plank canal oh I know where we
can use that I'm sure that's fine
what the actual [ __ ] Murray you know I'm
not gonna mess with that I am very
sexually intrigued those I might just
check it out
hello lost sexy beast okay all right I
don't know what I was expecting I don't
know what I was expecting
take the plank back because why not no
god that's there now are you kidding me
okay okay oh wow another one well I'm
making this game even more harder for me
okay you just gotta enter and leave and
he goes away got it
god damn I who needs me you can't truck
I'm used to plank on the board 1 4 3 5
Wow oh you what we're doing with the
life form you may ask easy oh my god
have a how have you not figured it out
yet you gotta put it on top of this guy
right remember this guy doesn't have a
head it fell off of course of course no
wasn't out that guy there was this guy
okay right so when you do that right
look how cute he looks adorable
oh wow it reveals that there's something
in the wallpaper good thing we have a
shard 1 4 3 5 give me that goddamn key
give me that [ __ ] sweet save saved
flip ins oh my god it's my man I don't
even care kill me oh my god he actually
killed me look at that look at that
another impossible puzzle area I assume
Wow look at that
and I died look at that it's the easiest
game I have ever played and the number
one gamer on YouTube okay oh look at
that a rug look at that a rug huh
I mean let me see what's what's
underneath you mister rug oh wow there's
a small key all along incredible it's
another puzzle I guess I need the Sun in
the moon that's cute
okay easy I'm having too much of an easy
time here guys can we step up the
difficulty please lighter oh it's a she
oh my god have I missed my man Takeshi
Hiroshi don't scare me like hey Rosie
don't scare me like the hey Takeshi
massacre you're alive yeah but that's
just a matter of time soon lady he will
get me there was no escape if only I
hadn't suggested to come here and none
of this would have happened
this is my phone Wow
Takashi I'm not gonna follow him I
actually okay there's a code that I
can't you know I'm sorry I love you I
love you too Casey please please be with
me I just have to solve these puzzles
Takeshi a little better help me it would
be nice that would be nice to get the
little bit of help II blingiest specky
she I love you Kenny
oh my you know oh my god
give me that Sun Sun flip okay we got
the Sun let's get there I mean the moon
what I keep saying son Jesus there it is
I got you
in my sight easy logical tests are easy
okay
all the rest are you kidding me no you
are kidding me no you are kidding me
I am so done with you sir padlock thank
you get me that [ __ ]
I remember this oh my god is so fast
look at me look at me come on what you
gonna do something do something what you
gonna do that's rad
that's rad hell yeah hell yeah oh yeah
man I'm playing for two hours I was
expecting this to be a cute little
playthrough a cute a cute one a cutesy
little playthrough with Port Byron
reminisce about the past okay clearly I
just need to enter the
boom oh I don't have the star oh no
where's the song no another puzzle no it
can't be
I have to get the plank again you have
to get the goddamn plank again yeah I
have to get to think again I have to get
I have to get the plank again the plank
is just the key to everything in this
game the goddamn plank I have to get the
plank again yes because of course of
course the pattern of the moon yes of
course one seven five four one seven
five bark would have been so blinded 175
oh of course yes one seven five four how
the hell did that Kesha get it this far
tell me that how did that stupid son of
a [ __ ] make it this far
hey we got the son piece we got the son
piece hell yeah we got the son who's
kept the son I got the son we get the
Sun on put that out and son click it in
give me they sheepdog hell yeah um
mother [ __ ] in Hiroshi Hiroshi oh that
doesn't look good
I should bring the others I remember
this I remember this bit but none of the
else cuz I'm wearing the wrong version
where are you Takeshi Takeshi man come
on don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] man don't be
a [ __ ] [ __ ] man
I gotta go and find out I don't even
remember Oh God I remember one look how
deep with gun look how far we've come
look how far we've come in this world
this world this world doesn't belong to
us
it belongs to comments all over the
world where the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] I
know he's here somewhere
somewhere deep in the oh my God all
these puzzles there she is come with me
come come come what but I found an
escape route
Wow then I just died I didn't even do
anything
I'm just gonna go [ __ ] this
[ __ ] everyone I don't even care what are
you gonna do I'm done I did it ha ha
oh my god I get the bad ending I just
skipped everyone was what was the real
identity of that monster I guess I will
never know that's it
there's not even there's not even ending
well I have to go now this took way
longer than I thought I'm sorry this is
anti-climatic I gotta go back we did it
we did it guys hell yeah
Bravo I feel great I feel so fulfilled
thank you very much for watching leave a
like enjoyed for nostalgia oh my god and
squad fam out maybe some maybe some
stuff is better left the way it is